hello and welcome i'm james murphy and
today we're talking about the md5
hashing algorithm
md5 stands for message digest 5
and what it does is it takes in a
message and outputs a summary
called a digest of the message change
the message by even one character
and the digest is supposed to be
completely different
the message can be any length but the
digest will always be
exactly 128 bits which we think of as
four 32-bit integers
md5 is what's called a hash function
which really just means it takes
messages of any length to a fixed length
but md5 wasn't intended to just be a
hash function
it was intended to be a secure hash
function
among other things you aren't supposed
to be able to find
inputs with a given hash or even two
inputs with the same hash
unfortunately md5 is not a secure hash
function
it's completely broken for cryptographic
use
but it's still important from a
historical perspective so let's take a
look at it
see an implementation of it and then
discuss some real world attacks against
it
but before we do do you know who's not
going to use a broken hash function like
md5
today's sponsor hosting her tri
hostinger's premium shared hosting plan
which has 99.9 guaranteed uptime
one free domain and free ssl certificate
and
a 30-day money-back guarantee use coupon
code m coding in all caps
at checkout to get up to 91 off on all
yearly plans
okay so let's just dive into the code
what i have here is an implementation of
the md5 algorithm
the first thing that we need to do is
decide what does md5 take in
and what does it spit out so what i
decided is that we're taking in bytes
and we're spitting out bytes
the way that we're going to do this is
basically we make
a state object which is going to keep
track of all the information of the
algorithm
we feed in whatever bytes that we have
and then we're going to have to do some
finalization and the reason for this is
because the md5 works on
blocks that are 512 bits long
64 bytes so if your input string
was not the correct length then it has
to get padded
and that's going to happen in this
finalization step
so down here i have basically the same
thing but instead i'm directly passing
in a file handle
we see that the md5 state object is
keeping track of four things
the most important one is this state
variable
at the end this state is going to be
what is ultimately made into the digest
the way that md5 works
is it operates on chunks of
512 bits at a time so the first thing is
that of course
we need to take in exactly 64 bytes and
then we convert those bytes
to integers so we take the whole chunk
and we convert 64 bytes into
16 integers then we start with the
process
of updating the state so we have four
variables a b c
d that make up our state variable
then we're going to go through 64 times
and basically mix in the message in a
particular way
so the general way that this works is
for each of the 64 steps
there is a mixer for that step
that's going to mix up bits and then
we're also going to mix up
which of the bytes that we use from the
message
the 64 steps of the algorithm are split
into four rounds of 16.
in the first round we use the f mixer in
the second round
we use the g mixer third round h mixer
fourth round i mixer
so this mixer for step whatever
is going to just tell you which of the
fghi
is going to be used for that step in the
algorithm
similarly we're not going to read the
message in order
and so in the first round you read
the 16 integers in this order in the
second round
we read it in a different order and so
we take the mixer for a given step
and we take the you know index
which integer do we want to read from
the message
at each step and we just put both of
those into big lists so that for every
step
we know which
int we're supposed to be reading out of
this array and which mixing function
we're supposed to use
so for all 64 steps we pick the correct
mixer
we pick the correct index for the
message that we're supposed to be using
and then we just use this formula we
take a
and then we throw bc and d in with the
mixer and then add that in
and then we add the message at the
specified index in
and then we add in this sign randomness
this is just another thing that's just
thrown in just because the algorithm
says two
okay so back to the main loop we
mix our bits we rotate our bits
then we add a to b and then we rotate
we take a b c d and you can see we take
the d
and we put it in front here so then we
have d
abc that's all there is to it after
we mix all of our bits up in this way 64
times
then whatever our state variables are
now
we add them to what they were at the
beginning so how do we ensure that we
actually do this for every 512 bits in
the message
well that's what the process function is
for so here's what we do in a loop
we try to read however many bytes it
takes to fill up our buffer and make a
full block size number of bytes
if our buffer was empty before and then
i read in
a full block size then i just go ahead
and call compress on the buffer
and then increase the length otherwise i
already had some bytes in my buffer
or i didn't read enough bytes in order
to fill up the buffer
so what i do in that case is i
note that you know i've now filled up
more bytes and if i filled up
now enough to do a compression if i
filled up the whole buffer
then i go ahead and compress and
increase the length and then set the
number of fill bytes back to zero
otherwise i
still haven't read enough bytes in order
to do another compression
so i just keep reading bytes until
i get to the end of the stream but what
happens when i get to the end of the
stream
and i've read some bytes but not enough
to fill up the entire 512 bits
to use a compression on it well then we
use this finalize method
to basically pad the end what we have to
do is
we append a one bit onto the end of the
message
and then we pad it with zeros in all
cases
we're going to pad with zeros and append
the length of the message that we just
read
as a 64-bit integer onto the end of the
message
but if adding that length onto the end
is going to overflow the block size then
we actually need to
do an extra compression so we might have
to
add on more zeros compress and then add
on the length
but in any case we're basically just
padding with exactly enough zeros
so that once we get to the end of the
message
we can add on our one bit our zero
padding
and then our eight bytes representing
the length so that it comes out exactly
to a multiple
of 512 bits and we do one last
compression
once we finalize the message then we
just need to output the digest or hex
digest
and the way this works is it's literally
just
these state variables whatever we
updated them to that's now what we
output as the digest
so why do we say that md5 is a
completely broken hash function at least
for cryptographic purposes
well it's susceptible to a number of
attacks and
for one here is a collision here's two
different messages that have the exact
same md5 hash
i know they look very very similar and
they are but they actually differ in two
places
zero zero zero two and d5 versus five
five
there are a bunch of different types of
attacks against hash algorithms
if you say you have a collision attack
against a hashing algorithm
then you're just saying you're in the
situation like i showed before with
these two messages
where you just have two different
messages that have the same hash
and that's not necessarily that useful
for an exploit
what would be more useful to an attacker
is something like a chosen prefix
attack it's given this name because
you can pick any two prefixes you want
like
this one says you know launch the nukes
and this one says
don't launch the nukes and then you can
add on
extra bytes different sets of bytes to
those two messages
and then whatever suffix you want after
that such that those two things have the
same hash
already in the real world there have
been several instances where either
researchers or
real hackers were able to use something
like a chosen prefix attack on md5
one instance they had a microsoft code
signature for one of their binaries
and they had microsoft sign something
that was completely innocuous
but that completely innocuous thing had
the same md5 hash
as a virus so whenever you're allowed to
control the prefixes like that
that's the case where you can really
start doing some damage okay so these
last two attacks
are just theoretical for md5 there's no
publicly known actual implementation
that can do
either of these things so a second
pre-image attack is basically
you've got a file or message that
already exists
and you want to find another message
with the same hash
you can imagine you have an operating
system a linux image
that lots of people are downloading and
a hacker could switch it out for
a different image that has the same hash
and a full pre-image attack
is basically the same thing but you
don't even need the file all you need is
the hash of the file
and that's all i've got thanks for
making it to the end don't forget to
like comment subscribe and check out our
sponsor in the link below